[Music]
I'm Adam I run board at home here we're
a board game shop specializing in
bringing board games to the whole family
we try to do as wide a range as possible
so we do things like Risk Cluedo
Monopoly the ones that a lot of families
will already know be familiar with these
are games that are kind of like a
stepping stone really into sort of The
Wider world of board game in and the way
that we've positioned the shop is to
sort of reflect that Journey so they
come in they can see the games that they
recognize and then as they work their
way through the shop the games will be a
bit more in-depth maybe a bit more Niche
but with their sort of help them through
that Journey
part of what we want to do with the shop
as well was to create a schedule of
events for people to come along and
experience the games that we sell here
so we have a games room downstairs with
about 250 games again
a similar kind of range to what we have
here so it kind of mirrors what we have
in stock we wanted to create a sort of
communal hub for people like this up
here is the shop but downstairs really
is the community space part of my
passion is that board games can bring
people together in a way that some other
media Maybe Can't and it's just created
a really nice sort of positive
atmosphere that people could come into
I'm hoping for a really good Christmas
this year again a lot of people have
discovered us over the last year and
we're still getting people coming by uh
in the run-up to Christmas this year
what I found a lot of people appreciate
here is they can pick a game up and I
research as much as I can here I try not
to have anything in here that I'm not
familiar with and I like that that gives
us a unique selling point over something
like Amazon where you can click and
there's people might put recommendations
up but
uh you're not going to get much more
support beyond that you can't look at it
you can't ask someone about it um you
can't pick it up and like feel it
the fact that people are so positive
about the shop but oh it's brought
people together there's a lot of
friendships that have been created
because of the events here that's very
rewarding to me that I've been able to
be part of something bigger than just
being a shop like the games room that
we've got
uh has been influenced by our customers
so there's stuff down there they've
donated for people to use to play other
games which we don't ask for but people
like have like an ownership almost they
feel part of something so they want to
contribute to that so that's
that's invaluable you know that's the
kind of stuff that makes me feel like
it's going to succeed and like helps us
survive is that passion from the
customers which
I don't think you get that with the
bigger shops you know they just go and
get their stuff and go uh but small
shops like this you know you really do
get a sense of community
thank you